foreign
Rochester New York hey Michelle how are
you
um so my husband and I are trying to
decide if we should move in with our
mother-in-law we are going to be seniors
in college we've been married two years
now
and there's two main reasons why we
would move the first is we would save
money probably we'd still pay her rent
but we'd probably save 400 a month
and the second reason is because she's a
single mom and her son is moving out to
get married so now she'll be in the
house alone and she doesn't like to be
alone
yes her son your husband the one that's
getting I know what it's my my husband's
twin brother oh okay
yeah so Michelle a reason to move in
with an in-law
under the um motivation because she
doesn't like to be alone that starts to
really entangle a relationship because
it sounds
like you're being kind
but it actually ends up being extremely
dysfunctional that she's depending it
upon you guys
the only way she's not alone is her
grown children stay home with her that's
dysfunctional I'll just say it that way
yeah okay I'm sorry this lady it's a
normal thing to cry when your grown kids
leave and cheer 20 minutes later it's a
normal thing to do that you do both okay
and uh to just cry and I don't wanna she
needs to have a life outside of her
children
okay I will say she is very
very self she still works no she's not
not emotionally
um
it's not that she I mean it was just
sort of an idea that was brought up and
we would only live with her for a year
and she knows that and
um she also like
I don't know
it's it's I guess in the situation it's
hard to describe but I'm not as much
concerned about her like if because
we've talked about not moving in and she
would just go on with life it's not like
a necessitative thing
yeah I think it's going to be better for
y'all and her emotionally and
relationally but that's not a
psychologist or a therapist speaking or
a pastor speaking that's just an old man
telling you
okay you do whatever you want to do and
do you guys is there a reason you know
you said you're going to save four
hundred dollars but there are juniors in
college you said right
uh we'll be seniors this year coming up
the twin brother and his new wife aren't
staying
uh well they're living in
um the new wife-in-law apartment with
her parents
so they sort of have their own situation
we had just talked about it like because
it was our last year of college it might
be nice to save money and take some of
the strain off of ourselves
yeah if you want to do it it's fine and
it's the way you presented it sounded
weird
okay sorry no that was I guess you
didn't you didn't it's not that it
sounded weird it just that our answer
changes or my I'll say my answer is more
cautious for you Michelle
because of the end of that it's not that
we're doing this for a financial goal
because some people do that right I mean
we we talk to people a lot that they're
like hey we're gonna make this move uh
because we have this goal and then we're
gonna be out there's a date it's very
specific all of that I'm not completely
against that it was the last part when
you said because she doesn't like to be
alone that's where my flag went up just
for you Michelle like woman to woman no
it goes up for her it goes up for your
husband too yeah that's what's weird I
mean that is weird so if that part
wasn't the end of it though and if your
only question was hey
it's our last year of college
and we're able to save some money if we
do this you know what do you guys think
about that if that was it
I would say and you're all in yeah and I
would say I mean yeah if that's what you
guys choose to do and but I would have
an end date I would not be living with
my in-laws over in a long extended
period of time as young newlyweds I
don't think that I think you guys
figuring out life just you guys together
is really healthy
um I would prefer that you didn't I
think you guys just figuring out life
together is is great
um but if you wanted to and had an end
date and all of that you it could be an
option it won't like
destroyed but it's that end that other
part of the question that I'm like oh
just don't you know what what I heard
was just codependence and I don't I
wouldn't I don't recommend that for
anybody
um you know if uh because there's not an
end there's not an end of that that
needy that neediness is not something
that needs to be fed it needs to be
healed and that's that's all I was
saying just from again that's just old
man talking so it's not there's no
professional quote guidance there you
you called us and ask our opinion so and
I don't think she's a bad lady I think
she's just normal it's normal she's got
two twin boys they're the last two to
leave yeah and uh and she's a single mom
and they they've been her world and
that's a normal grieving of that yes but
it's also a release
that and and you know she don't have a
choice she's got to move on with the
next chapter of her life and you guys
can't run over there every time she's
lonely yep um that's that's uh yeah okay
anyway I'll set our Pace be careful be
careful be careful